menu du jour de petits sablés pour le
côté dans la semaine du goût la maison
de quartier du bois de l'étang de la
verrière organise un atelier cuisine les
apprentis cuisiniers on commence par
bien malaxer la pâte on travaille où
tous les apports énergétiques des
aliments donc là les enfants sont en
atelier cuisine sur la préparation d'un
goûter équilibré donc l'atelier spa sont
deux parties donc là c'est les petits
sablés et cet après midi on aura le
milkshake et les brochettes de fruits et
puis à 4 heures tous se retrouvent
autour d'un grand goûter les chefs d'un
jour ont entre 6 et 11 ans et découvre
l'intérêt de la farine du sucre et du
lait on explique un petit peu les
ingrédients qui sont nécessaires à
l'élaboration du plan voilà pour le coup
c'est des petits sablés donc du coup à
leur montrer un petit peu quels sont les
intérêts des différents ingrédients qui
interviennent dans la recette allez voir
du coup voilà ce qui ce qui est
important pour eux et par les deux
secondes ils ont besoin les enfants
nettoie ensuite le plan de travail pour
y disposer la pâte le découpage des
futurs petits sablés se fait dans les
règles de l'art une fois disposé dans le
plat il n'y a plus qu'à mettre au four
dans dix minutes il sera temps de
déguster